so i've been recommending the magic
keyboard case for the ipad pro for
months now
since it literally takes your ipad to
the next level
and it actually makes it feel like a
macbook
and what does this is the fact that it
has a built-in
trackpad and this trackpad works
flawlessly
that's the main reason why i absolutely
do not recommend
the bridge pro plus keyboard case the
trackpad is
horrible and you're gonna end up being
disappointed
even though you saved money compared to
the magic keyboard
which works incredibly well and it's
about to get even better with ipad os 14
now that apple is allowing game
developers to add
keyboard and mouse gaming to the ipad
which is an absolute game changer so
your best choice was just to invest
300 dollars for the magic keyboard case
and have an
excellent overall experience however
there is one huge reason why you should
actually
wait and hold off on buying that magic
keyboard case
just yesterday logitech announced their
brand new folio touch keyboard case
with the trackpad for the ipad pro and
it's only
dollars so it's basically half off the
price of the magic keyboard
and it has two major benefits compared
to the magic keyboard which i'll get
into in just a moment
but first i want to mention two things
number one is that this keyboard totally
came as a surprise
and number two is that our premium apple
product hoodie is
incredibly soft and you can find it in
our merch shelf right below this video
about four months ago when the magic
keyboard case was just released
logitech also released trackpad keyboard
cases
for the ipad and the ipad air so it's
obvious that logitech was working
closely with apple to get it done
however they didn't release one for the
11 inch ipad pro
and now i finally know why if logitech
released this 160
keyboard case at the same time as
apple's magic keyboard
there would be a lot of people who would
have chosen this cheaper one instead so
what apple did was they made a deal with
logitech
where they wouldn't be able to sell
their folio touch for the ipad pro
until four months after the magic
keyboard case went up for sale
yes this does suck for the people who
would have preferred
to just buy the cheaper case instead but
in reality
the magic keyboard case is so good and
totally unique
that people who bought it are extremely
happy with it
almost every comment we received from
people who actually bought the magic
keyboard case
is very positive but right now
everything has
changed and honestly this logitech folio
touch
for 160 dollars is an absolutely
killer deal and i honestly think they
should have priced it at two hundred
dollars
because it's gonna kill the two hundred
dollar bridge pro
plus keyboard case the number one reason
why it's so good
is because it's the only third party
case for the new ipad pro
that can take advantage of the smart
connector
everyone else has to use bluetooth using
the smart connector means you have a
hardwired connection
from the ipad to the keyboard and the
trackpad
this means absolutely no lag no
reliability issues that come with
bluetooth
and no batteries that need to be
recharged
i know all of this because this new
folio touch keyboard case
is almost identical to the combo touch
that i already reviewed and compared to
the magic keyboard case
the only difference is the cutout at the
top for the apple pencil's wireless
charging
and the fact that the keyboard portion
isn't detachable
because the smart connector is on the
back of the ipad pro instead of on the
side
so based on my experience with the combo
touch for the budget ipad
this new folio touch for the ipad pro is
gonna work flawlessly
the trackpad experience was perfect and
the most important feature
is that it supports all of the same
gestures that you get with the magic
keyboard case
like swiping up with three fingers to go
to the home screen
swiping side to side with three fingers
to switch between apps
and perfectly smooth scrolling and
swiping
which you don't get with the bridge pro
plus keyboard case
so now i want to finally get into the
two major benefits
compared to the magic keyboard case
other than the obvious price difference
this folio touch actually has a top row
of function keys
which is probably the number one thing
that people complained about with the
magic keyboard
since it doesn't have that so now you
have an escape button to take you to the
home screen
you have brightness controls keyboard
backlighting controls
media controls like volume and more and
the other major feature is that you can
actually flip the keyboard portion
under the ipad pro so you can lay it
flat on a table
and more conveniently use your apple
pencil to draw or take notes
which isn't possible on the magic
keyboard case unless you take the ipad
pro
off and as a bonus this folio touch case
actually protects the sides of the ipad
pro which the magic keyboard
doesn't and it uses a very nice
fabric-like material
that won't get scuffed up over time like
the magic keyboard could
so all of that sounds great and honestly
for only 160 dollars
it's hard to justify spending the extra
cash on the magic keyboard
but there are also some downsides with
logitech's case
first of all there isn't a version for
the 12.9 inch model of the ipad pro
so if you have one of those the best
option is still
the magic keyboard case and another
downside of the folio touch is that it's
a lot thicker
than apple's case here's how the combo
touch version for the ipad compared
now it won't be this big of a difference
but it's definitely more thick
and finally there are three totally
unique features
that you get on the magic keyboard that
you can't get
on the new folio touch but instead of
just talking about those features i'm
gonna
show them to you when we receive it on
monday and compare it to the magic
keyboard
so if you're not already subscribed do
so right now
down below so you don't miss out because
that's gonna be a very
in-depth hands-on comparison and you'd
be surprised
you might actually want to spend the
extra 140
on the magic keyboard case based on
those three features
but if you're 100 dead set on buying
this folio touch
i'm going to leave some links down below
so you can order one before it goes out
of stock because i think these are gonna
fly off the shelves
but until monday if this video helped
you out go ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on that comparison
video
and be sure to check out our apple
product merch right below this video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one